all right this is part two of our ask
Dave for today I tweeted out the link on
aura TV to ask some questions and you
guys gave us a ton so here we go Andrew
asked are you a libertarian yet I get a
ton of messages asking me this I
wouldn't say I'm a libertarian yet I do
like a lot of things about
libertarianism about Liberty about
limited government and you doing with
your life what you want to and in the
privacy of your own home whether you
want to be gay in your bedroom or smoke
pot in your bedroom those things are up
to you
classic liberalism and libertarianism
are extremely close together and I want
to explore that a little bit more I'm
gonna try to get some professors and
authors on here who can really help me
dig into that but I wouldn't say I'm
quite there yet but I'm evolving I
evolved on the show every week mr. Jack
MB given how our aggressive many student
unions in the UK and the u.s. sir
becoming with no platforming policies
and speech codes and forests on campuses
should students who deeply care about
the free exchange of ideas distance
themselves from them or seek to reform
them from the inside I mean this is just
a question of tactics right so we know
about all of this stuff even some of my
former guests like my liliane appleís
and ben shapiro
and steven crowder these guys are all on
the right right but they've been going
to campuses and they get they get
protested now it's absolutely your use
of free speeches to protest people but
if you go in and you don't let them
speak or you're pulling fire alarms or
things like that then then we have a
social contract here you've got to let
people speak and then use your speech to
beat them with better ideas so as far as
doing it from the inside or the outside
I think you probably need both in both
movements but the most important thing
is is pushing your good ideas you know
all of these kids that think that by
silencing milah innopolis or silencing
ben shapiro that you're winning you're
actually losing because you're you're
denying yourself and the people around
you to be challenged and guess what the
more you get challenged if your ideas
are good you'll double down and
you'll get better at explaining them and
spreading your own good ideas
Stevie AF said when you're gonna
interview doctor Bill Warner so I became
familiar with dr. Warner on God's ads
Channel he did a really interesting
interview with him he is he comes from a
science background and he talks about
political Islam so he treats his
critiques of all the religions and he
studied all of the religions at least
the main three Western ones and some of
some others I think he treats their
critique in a scientific manner I think
he's really brilliant and he really has
been trying to make the distinction the
difference between Islamism meaning the
political movement of Islam and the
religious side of it which is a
distinction that no matter how many
times as you guys know no matter how
many times we try to make or anyone
tries to make people people seem to
conflate and confuse all the time so I
have been in touch with Bill Warner and
it's gonna happen in the next couple
weeks mr. Tyrone if you had to vote
Republican including all of the
candidates who would you have voted for
I assume you know all the candidates
that that ran in this last cycle I say
if I had to pick any of them and I was
not really impressed by any of them but
if I had to pick any of them I probably
would have picked Rand Paul because I
think he was right on a lot of the NSA
stuff again smaller government and
liberty you know interestingly though
Rand Paul for a libertarian you know if
he was he wasn't quite there on gay
marriage he was trying to punt it back
to the state it's a moot point and
people are tired of talking about it and
the Supreme Court already made their
decision but if he was trying to be a
principled libertarian then he would say
well I don't care marry whoever you want
or even on medical marijuana he wasn't
quite there and he is a doctor so I
don't think it was a great group of
people
I think if his voice had stayed in
longer has a little more of a moderating
force then maybe we wouldn't be where
we're at right now Matt so scene says
why don't you push back more on your
guests that say things that have no
basis in fact okay so I think probably
the I don't know 90% of what you guys
send me on email or Twitter Facebook is
all positive it's all positive or you're
sharing some view or expressing
something going on in your life all
great I think the one critique
I get more than any other is that people
think that I sometimes don't push back
on my guests hard enough so I guess I
this is a good time for me to just
explain a little bit of my view of just
my philosophy of interviewing people
which is that I let people speak and I
think if you give them rope either they
will show you their good ideas those
things will shine forth and they'll show
you a clean line of thinking and they'll
show you that they know what they're
talking about and they have command of
the issues that they're talking about or
you'll give them a long enough rope that
they'll hang themselves and I think that
is that's the way that I prefer to
interview but you might like in a way
that somebody else says I don't need to
show the person that's sitting across
from me that I'm somehow smarter than
them or a morally superior or anything
yeah sometimes I have to pick and choose
when to push back so for example when I
had my load on and a couple weeks ago
you guys know that a gajillion times
I've made the distinction between the
nominal Muslim person and radical
jihadists a thousand cons he did not and
I even said to him Milo I'll save you
some hate here do you want to make that
distinction do you want to go ahead and
make that and he said no I don't he
didn't want my my help in that regard
now right now you can make your judgment
call on him steven crowder I got a ton
of hate last week for having steven
crowder on from people on the left that
are supposed to be open to new ideas
just for sitting down with the guy you
have to be willing to sit down with
someone let him express his ideas his or
her ideas and then let the chips fall
where they may if the ideas are shitty
well then guess what they're they're not
gonna win a lot of followers so I have
to pick and choose when I do it and I
think the most important thing is having
the discussions instead of yelling at
each other which if you want people yell
at each other there's a good jillion
other channels for you to find out
Benbow two four seven says do you prefer
interviewing liberal guests or
conservative guests you know what I
really don't think about it either way I
think I like interviewing people that I
think are intellectually honest or at
least intellectually consistent who are
smart who who are gonna challenge some
of my thoughts I think pretty much every
week that I've interviewed somebody here
we've done about 30
for shows or so that I've learned
something and I've tried to apply the
whatever I've learned in into the next
week's show and sometimes I learn things
that not because someone said something
that I agree with but because they says
I don't agree with and that makes me
understand my line of thinking a little
bit more so I don't really care if
they're liberal or conservative sadly
that where I'm at right now because of
this whole regressive left thing is that
I do find it easier to sit across
sometimes from conservatives and and
have a discussion and have us back and
forth and disagree with them versus if I
was going to have some of the regressive
people on a show who have so
consistently proven that their that
their intentions are not good because
some of the tactics they use and by the
way that is no defense of some of the
tactics that the right uses but as I
always say I'm trying to clean up my
side that sort of gets to this question
which is from Rob and he said hey Dave
would you ever consider inviting those
that hail from the regressive left to be
on your show so first off I'm really
happy to talk to anyone short of unless
you're just someone that's absolutely
spewing like true vile hate or real
bigotry or you know like real just
awfulness I would talk to pretty much
anybody so as for the regressives yeah I
mean sure Jane Reza Glenn you want to
come on the show here I here it is you
let's let's do it
Martin so I've heard you outline a lot
of problems with the regressive left and
I do not disagree but where do we go
next it's not like the right own or new
center have any amazing ideas to further
the progress of mankind in any
meaningful way right now it's just a
bunch of people talking in circles you
have the option to take your show
further so I love this question this is
probably my favorite question that we
got where do we go well look we had to
address this right so something's
happened here there's no doubt the
amount of growth that we've had it took
us about two and a half years to get to
a hundred thousand subscribers on
YouTube
any day now probably tomorrow or the
next day we're gonna hit 200,000 just in
the last six months and that's just on
YouTube and we're on hora and we're on
roku and all kinds of other places and
where the shows on itunes now and all
that and just from the general response
we get and everything else something has
happened
here and I'm not the only one doing it
by the way the plenty of the people that
I've had on my show have been huge
voices in this from from GAD and Sam and
Majid and Christina Hoff Sommers and and
everybody else but yeah you can't just
address the problem without a solution
one of my big issues with the regresses
is that they're always just fighting
everybody instead of trying to promote
better ideas so I think we're getting
close to the time where they won't even
be relevant it won't even be important
for me to be talking about the
regressives because it'll be understood
that this group exists and now we have
to not only beat them with better ideas
which I think we're doing already but
now we have to find some solutions so
maybe that'll be the next sort of shift
of where the show goes I look forward to
finding out abhishek said do you find in
our fight against the regressive left
that we have unintentionally shared the
bed with all right ideologies of climate
change denial anti abortion Western
supremacism this is a good question too
you know a few people have said this to
me that by being so critical of the
regressives
am i somehow in bed now with the right i
am not again i have literally never
voted for a Republican ever in my entire
life right so for those issues so
climate change you know I had a climate
change scientists on here one of the top
climate change scientists in the country
dr. Michael Mann and we did an entire
episode an entire hour long episode with
him sharing his ideas and what he's
learned scientifically on climate change
so yes then I had Crowder on last week
and Crowder doesn't believe in manmade
climate change and quoted some sort of
loosely understood polls of scientists
or something and I said well now you
guys here I had the climate change
scientists on for an hour I had this
conservative on to say this and now you
can decide you know that also goes to
something like I disagree with crowd
around on abortion I'm pro-choice he's
pro-life but there's there's some way
you can have that discussion without
demonizing everybody so for me as I said
in the interview with him at some point
that life you can't just tell me that
two weeks before a nine-month pregnancy
is do that if you have an abortion
you're not killing someone that just
seems crazy to me
we have to have the honest discussion
about well okay if you're gonna say well
you can't have abortions after four
months let's say so you're pro-choice
for the first four months and then after
that you believe that there's a life
there well then does the government then
have a role to help those people or not
but we have to have that discussion so I
don't think I'm aligning with those
people at all what I'm trying to do is
show some of their ideas without
demonizing them because that's how you
have a healthy healthy discussion and
that's how you move forward actually
Ches third Somers says after you die
what do you wish people to remember you
most by that is depressing I think
hopefully that I tried to have some
honest discussion here that you guys got
to understand the way I think and the
things that I care about and that maybe
I was a little ahead of the curve when
it came to some of this stuff and that
through this show and what I do and
getting my ideas out there that I help
some good ideas kind of percolate on the
way up that would be pretty good it's a
lot to put on a tombstone what is the
best worst best and worst film you've
ever seen this is at Eric Moreau zyk
I've said this couple names my favorite
movie of all time is contact it just it
was written by Carl Sagan the great
scientist it was his only fiction book
which then became a novel or became a
movie with with Jodie Foster I just love
the the scientific use it's sci-fi but
it's really based in science very much
the way interstellar was and I think a
worst movie I ever saw it was just a
couple weeks ago on Netflix I saw the
ridiculous six which is one it you know
Adam Sandler has this deal with Netflix
I think four six maybe or four or six
movies and it was just the worst garbage
I have ever seen it wasn't even a movie
it was like the most loosely tied
together just unfunny drivel I tried to
laugh halfway through I was like I gotta
try to laugh at some point and I could
not do it it was watch it just to see
what like true horror it was a horror
movie after you more than a comedy Danby
s official if you were offered to host a
late-night show would you sure why not
what do you got for me Dan let me know
alright thank you guys we're gonna keep
doing these and I appreciate the support
and
and they were literally probably another
100 questions that we didn't get to so
just keep doing them and we'll keep
doing this and that's